welcome to the show we have a decoy
story today did you suspect that we had
a decoy story today I suspected we had a
decoy story today we have today for
Pat's birthday a very very special thing
going on how did you suspect that there
was a decoy story is it because this is
not the way I write stories that's not
the right way yeah it's not the way that
you write stories and also you did the
same thing last year too and right so
just copy and paste an article into the
show notes so I'm coming but there's not
many ways to do it so I'm very happy we
have a decoy story today it is Pat's
birthday over the weekend and to
celebrate Pat's increased maturity we
have gotten Pat a gift that represents a
sort of curated maturity which is we
have gotten Pat two nice bottles of
bourbon okay and we are going to be
having a bourbon tasting on today's
program max has been coordinating with
me to get all of this set up and this is
going to I'll get those out it we don't
want to show that whoa no get those that
we almost expose we don't want to give
any hints as to what is going on here
so we have two different bottles of
bourbon and what we're going to try to
determine is if in Pat's increasingly
increasing intelligence and refinement
we he and I can distinguish between the
less nice and the more nice bottle of
bourbon that we have gotten and I have
absolutely no idea I don't really know
that much about bourbon but I've had
good bourbon and mediocre bourbon and I
like to think that I'd be able to
identify which what's good and what's
not good yeah I'm used to just bottom of
the barrel whiskey correct my taste buds
are probably not going to be able to
decipher between that's exactly right
and the great thing is no matter whether
we succeed the taste in the tasting or
not both bottles are yours to keep as a
gift and you know one one is better than
the other but you're gonna be able to
have both and at least one of these is
very very good as a mixer so arrive home
with the open containers yes that is
actually a problem so we've got I'm
gonna let's see if I can turn these cups
this way are you gonna be joining us in
tasting max max is not joining us in
tasting okay Wow max has work to do max
is actually busy so we have two Bourbons
here now max did you place these in
front of us
in a particular way so that we know
exactly what's going on you didn't so
how are we going to know which is the
nicer one
oh you you've marked the bottom so oh
okay let's not look at the bottom of
these should we taste them in any
particular order we should okay so
another question is it legal to drink
alcohol and American television I know
you can't do that with advertising we
are not bound by broadcast standards and
this could all be theater of the mind
anyway okay right so like these are
these are just green cups that are
unlabeled so they could be anything we
could be pretending it's a false flag
story about a false flag story that's
exactly right that's exactly right
so let's why don't we do tasting of
these and see what we can figure out
here and of course being older than Pat
you would think that my palate would be
more refined at this point so first
thing I'm gonna do is just smell these
okay III already think that I know and
I'm going just based on smell one of
these to me has it if you were to take
you know the smell that really cheap
beer has yeah if you were to translate
that over to bourbon I think that one of
these has a particularly cheap bearish
smell okay I think I know which one it
is I am now going to sample the first
one and you can do the same Pat and
we'll see if we can identify these okay
the first one is quite smooth it has an
aftertaste that I would describe a
slightly spicy now I don't know which
one you tried first I don't know how
would you characterize the taste of this
first one mmm like alcohol okay very
good so we're on the same page as far as
that goes I'm now gonna try the second
one this is the one that I think is
actually the nicer one I feel like the
second one which I identified on the
basis of smell as the nicer one is
actually the nicer one even though it
does have more bite after the fact yeah
I got nothing you got nothing on it I
mean I taste both of them they taste
same to you they taste the exact same
yeah do they taste the same to you max
no they don't they definitely don't
taste the same to me I'm gonna do one
more round
and then we're gonna have to vote and
see if we are right I hope the show gets
out today unn smell now I think I'm
confusing myself now I think the first
one actually is the more is the nicer
one I'm gonna take one more taste and
see here I think I might guess I'm
actually reversing my feel I think that
the one I identified as the cheaper one
with the beer smell that beer smell has
completely disappeared and I think it's
actually now huh you're supposed to be
the experienced one with I don't refined
I don't know anything all right I am
going to say and I'll put these out in
front of me this one to my left I
believe is the more expensive of the two
Bourbons I think that the one to my
right is the least expensive of the two
Bourbons before we do the reveal why not
you without looking Pat designate which
is which I'm going to say this is the
more expensive bourbon yeah and this is
the less expensive bourbon so you say
the less expensive one is on your left
on my left I'm gonna do the first reveal
I said that the Bourbon on my left was
the more expensive one what am I looking
for underneath it an X X is the
expensive one and I am wrong okay let's
just make sure this one has an X neither
has an X no I'm kiddin around
okay I can't max thought he gave Pat
both of the expensive ones no I so I'm
completely wrong all right so you said
that the ones who you're right was the
expense yeah if I get this right this is
a huge win in the battle of ideas
absolutely take a look a look I got no X
so we were both wrong oh yeah those are
clueless about this stuff well I guess
the takeaway is you don't have to spend
too much money on expensive bourbon
that's exactly right a cheaper stuff
tastes just about the same I should have
gotten even cheaper bottles is the the
takeaway here well listen Pat
congratulations on your birthday today's
not your birthday but about your
birthday I mean do you have anything
major planned for your birthday
gotta watch the World Cup Finals and the
comfort of my own home right Croatia
defeat France as we're all looking
forward to I am rooting for France but
we will we will see we have to make sure
that this video gets published before
the game or that you're going to look
really really stupid I believe that
this is excellent bourbon actually both
see the thing is neither one of these is
actually a bad bottle but one of them is
just decidedly a better bottle and so I
think that if I had act I didn't want to
skimp on Pat's birthday and get like a
$10 bottle of bourbon no I'm guessing
and I'm going to hope that if I had
gotten a $10 bottle we would have been
able to identify that right and I'm
guessing it also would have been much
less noticeably less smooth well even a
$10 bottle I would be very grateful for
yeah I'm very happy that you did this
David and Max and know and everyone else
and I'm grateful for the audience
I love participating on our reddit for
reading and I love hydrating happy in
this job and I'm very glad that you did
this thing please make memes of Pat with
the cops okay
whether it's drinking out of the cups
smelling out of the cups or when he
lifts the cups and looks underneath the
cups I think that there is a
significantly meme friendly material in
those yeah we have the whole rest of the
show to record now we're both drunk how
we're gonna do this it's gonna be very
very tough so happy birthday to Pat it
is the Friday show go France in the
World Cup and they may lose and we will
then retroactively Li edit this out of
archives of the show thank you